[Music]
how many people in here use their phone
while they're driving
for directions block folio
yeah dude it's fdx now ftx now look down
just both i always but i have a lot of
uh courtesy and manners so i always
write sorry for the typos i'm driving
but honestly though texting and driving
isn't that hard bro it's not that hard
why don't you guys do the voice thing
yeah like i used that car play thing and
then or apple play whatever it's called
and then i don't really text that much
while i drive but people that text and
drive they're just so bad at it because
they're completely focused on their
phone and they're not even looking at
the road they drive like this they'll
slow down at 20 miles an hour to text
and then that's my biggest gripe that's
actually driving i've definitely seen
people in their free before like driving
80 and they're just like looking down
the whole time like this i saw someone
reading a newspaper oh i see someone
reading a script for real yeah they were
reading a newspaper and then i saw one
time somebody was reading a script while
they were driving holy i saw somebody
eat spaghetti meatballs when they're
driving
that's actually not that bad
that's not that bad not like a whole
plate i'd like bowl of cereal white
dressing like the twist twist
like that
that's pretty good though that's the way
to eat spaghetti meatballs though like
like when i used to when i was in high
school i see my breakfast on the way to
school and so i was like i've seen your
bowls noodle soup noodle soup so i was
like eating noodle soup how's the soup
not [ __ ] spill i don't know he's like
initial d dude wow you don't drive that
crazy dude but i was like
when i was driving
you know what's amazing
it's driving and doing makeup oh that's
[ __ ] amazing that's crazy dude
because they could do [ __ ] eyeliner
and [ __ ] and they don't even pick their
i mean they don't even like poke their
eye dude or if i'm driving and nikki's
doing makeup next to me she's like you
gotta [ __ ] tell me before you break
and i'm like this [ __ ] [ __ ] broke
yeah what do you want me to do what am i
gonna do
that kind of [ __ ] yeah
my worst one uh like 10 years ago i used
to drive a manual honda accord coupe ooh
manuals are fun yes so stick shift on
that while being on like the phone while
like packing a bowl of weed and eating
and eating a spaghetti sandwich let's go
dude that was like i was reckless i want
to drive with this guy we were
multitaskers that's true people people
really do suck when they text and drive
like it's like just be better at it or
if you're gonna do it just be better at
it or don't do it
i saw this girl she was we were all at a
stoplight right she was just on her
[ __ ] phone she was so deep in her
text she didn't even realize that there
was a cop right next to us
and the light was [ __ ] green
it turned green and then he was looking
at her and he's like
and then she was just
good oh man
and she looked up she goes oh my god oh
my god and then she drove straight and
he didn't he didn't do [ __ ]
see what's the point of that thing dude
nah she was like
you got to give that lady a ticket how
many seconds until you bust
what do we need to get back to the bart
skill
[ __ ] three hours scale three hours okay
is that like constant stroking or is
that a whoa mike that's a weird [ __ ]
michael you said buzz man it's just a
quick question man yeah dude
it was this beautiful thing that we did
yeah what a weird detail
you made it weird michael uh so police
broke it dude
police in canada say they they were
working on uh distracted drivers they
had a little initiative they want to
pull over more distracted drivers right
and so they pulled over this guy who was
obviously distracted
and the officer walked up to the window
expecting to see
a cell phone but instead he saw that
they were holding a flute
the cop says that the driver was quote
following along to a song on an ipod
while playing
that's crazy
you gotta send that out of jail play
some careless whispers
how are you gonna drive while you're
playing
bro if you're playing kenny g you have
to get arrested yo honestly though he's
just serious about him he's practicing
you know what i mean sometimes you got
to get your practice no dude because
you're not getting real practice [ __ ]
that you should go to jail maybe he's
going to band practice and he wants to
show up knowing his [ __ ] but how do you
drive yeah i should kill himself with a
severe sword is this [ __ ] with a
flute like this and he's just using this
to control the wheel
he's using this well you just need the
knee technique the knee technique
actually works pretty well on straight
away i don't i've never
i never used my knee before to drive how
do you do that oh dude it's really
simple it's actually the best method to
drive i always strive to with their knee
i drive with my finger
but then you still need hands yeah no
she would go like this
i tried to u-turn my knee before it's
really hard all the way up here yeah you
got to like put the pressure on from the
front side and then you got to be able
to go like this and then sink into it
i'm going to try yeah tall enough i
can't no i can't i couldn't do it i'm
saying it's really hard i'm going to try
i tried
maybe it's it's the short legs that's
the flute oh what the dude you gotta say
that the evidence yeah and this guy was
charged with distracted drug good he's
going away for a long time
good take his ass to jail no just stick
that flute in his [ __ ] mouth and make
him deep throw it
i'm one of those dudes that's like your
years of justice here is [ __ ]
we're not gonna stop people from being
distracted you know what i'm saying like
people are always gonna do it so it's
kind of like that's why more smart cars
or like tesla's like self-driving ones
or i think it should just be more
realistic like when you're getting your
driver's license a part of it should be
distracted driving and can you drive
distract like just make the test
like applicable to how it plays out in
real life the driving test is too easy i
think you should have to drive you
should have to be able to perform
execute a text while you're driving you
should be able to
make trades on your [ __ ] wallet or
your crypto make an instagram post while
you're driving you know during the dip
and you have to make the trade before it
goes back up while also being able to
make a left turn that's like that that
hacker movie swordfish or some [ __ ] when
that guy had a hat hitting a dick yeah
that's a great scene by the way yeah
it's like that should be the dmv test
dude for real i think so
he tests his road head yup you got to
get road head while you're driving
you're like [ __ ] i got the wrong driving
instructor
that's the district you got to give
roadhead while you drive yeah oh that's
hard oh yeah you got to jack the dude
off while you're driving yeah that'd be
good no
nose up for that one huh like what i
don't like yours
this is the most realistic
i don't know about that one
you're like a san francisco driving
instructor
[Laughter]
i don't get it what do you mean driving
[ __ ] stick shift in san francisco is
one of the worst things
bro that's what i did in l.a bro [ __ ]
driving my truck stick shift was
horrible everywhere i went my left leg
is like completely numb
because of the clutch that's right the
scary thing is when you stall out in san
francisco your car [ __ ] rolls back
dude because of the hills
you don't get it perfectly you're going
down you have to do [ __ ] at san
francisco where you pull the handbrake
you know what i mean you're just waiting
there and then and then you gotta slowly
press that and then you're like okay
cool i'm good but i got really good
after that though if you roll back too
far you're not gonna stick
dude i'm so glad that i don't have a
stick because now i can text and drive
much easier yeah so but it's so much
easier to text and drive while you're uh
have automatic but that's why people got
tesla's right so you could text and
drive because even that big ass is a
tech screen yeah tesla
do you think people are worse drivers
these days oh [ __ ] yeah yeah it's worse
than it's ever been yeah people don't
even look over their shoulder now when
they turn when they signal no or this
guy doesn't what i mean
i always look over my shoulder and i
signal dude
bart goes good luck everybody nobody
knows how to [ __ ] merge dude
when you merge with somebody perfectly
they have their blinker on i have my
blinker on and then we perfectly merge
nothing gets my dick harder dude it's
like synchronized driving
no dude when it's perfect
or when i go and the guy waits and he's
like breaking the whole time and then he
signals over after i've made my move
that guy's a piece of [ __ ] dude you
might what pisses me off is if you come
in my lane
and you don't wave i'm like where's my
wave where's my [ __ ] wave i wave all
the time too even if it's raining i roll
down my window a little bit oh thank you
yeah in hawaii they go shaka dude they
go thank you very much thank you they're
like shoots they do that see i think the
problem with especially for like anybody
who's in like california or la us maybe
in general right it's like everybody's
so entitled which is why we we feel
comfortable with the text because you
assume that everybody's following the
same rules as each other it's right it's
like this is my lane this is my right of
way if the light's green i'm not
expecting a pedestrian so you don't pay
attention because you think that like
the system means i should go versus like
really paying attention what might be
happening regardless of the system
whereas you go to like china or india or
vietnam or where there's like no
intersections there's no street lights
riding in vietnam and everybody kind of
has to like anybody could die at any
moment so almost everybody drives safe
because they're paying attention i like
that i feel like they drive safe but in
that dangerous way because it doesn't
look safe it doesn't look safe it
doesn't look it and yet over here people
are driving like 85 miles an hour and
then hitting [ __ ] and [ __ ] flying out
the window it's just a different driving
culture because it didn't look safe
because we i didn't get it but when i
when i started riding i was like oh [ __ ]
this is actually pretty nice yeah it's
just like it's like when you walk at the
mall that there's like a oh like you're
like you're right you're like a pool
he's walking into people even though
there's no order yeah you just always
you're aware dude you're not
like over here like you know if you bump
it if i bump into nick at like
disneyland oh shoot my back so over
there like i'll see people like get
little fender benders and they just look
oh i show my back
and everyone's coming nobody died yeah
like there's like little scrapes in
there but here it's like it could be a
little tap oh my god let me get your
insurance
in the middle of the freeway you got to
get the [ __ ] out stop all of traffic
it's like a little thing and everyone
gets [ __ ] like look at my bmw while
in asia they got a [ __ ] golden
retriever that they're holding while
they're riding their mopeds yeah with a
family of six on their [ __ ] [ __ ] i
seen that [ __ ] i remember this one time
when uh i was in beijing and we went to
go see the uh the uh like i forgot some
monument thing right and so basically
like really made an impact
it was something a wall of china it
wasn't the great wall of china temple it
wasn't a shaman temple what was it
basically so we were going this way
right and we were all the way on like
the left side so like and then um the
entrance to the monument was on the
other side and so basically we had to uh
i was like well you know driver we could
just be dropped off here you know over
here and then you know we could take the
underground tunnel and walk to the
entrance which is you know not that far
away but then the driver is like no you
guys i want to take you to the very
front so he basically he decided to do
like a massive u-turn from the left
no it was free because my friend had a
driver so he we were in the left mostly
he does a u-turn across like 10 lanes
and then he ends this up like right in
the front of the monument did he cut
anyone off though he caught off tons of
people
like one two three just like made the
massive left massive u-turn and then we
were right there i don't mind if people
bust the crazy if it doesn't affect
anybody yeah affect anybody i'm pretty
sure people honked at him no it affects
everybody out there but still it's like
no accidents and everybody gets where
they need to go i think there's a new
rule that should be made in the u.s if
you're driving on a clear straightaway
and there's no crosswalks and somebody's
jaywalking but that person is like
taking their time knowing that the
driver's not going to hit them i feel
like you should be able to hit that
pedestrian that's good new york style
yeah i think that's the way in new york
the cavs will bump you a little bit
these [ __ ]
cruise by jaywalking acting like you
ain't gonna hit me they won't even look
over their shoulder for other cars and i
feel like they should be hit by cars
yeah especially the old ladies with the
[ __ ] walkers taking so long
that [ __ ] i'm just kidding i'm talking
about cool guys i'm talking about cool
guys
yeah i feel like if people don't choose
to acknowledge you then you get to not
have to acknowledge them exactly i think
that's a great role right versus like
somebody walking down the street like
second like somebody looks and you're
like okay you're conscious of me i want
to be conscious of you today every time
i see one of those shoppers too
i'm like what the [ __ ] are you why are
you shopping out here why do you have a
[ __ ]
they're pushing this card along and i'm
like don't [ __ ] shop here dude
[Music]